we have hector mejia live this afternoon
with a look at how workers stuck outside
are trying to stay safe in the heat
hector
hey there yeah standing here we can
really hear feel the intensity of this
heat and here at this job site by
decatur and blue diamond road
sr construction says that they have a
trailer this one right here
where workers can step inside cool off
and hydrate
they've also had to adjust your schedule
around the scorching temperatures
it's a challenge we've actually started
earlier
we start at 5 30 now because the heat
index
keeps going up when it keeps going up it
actually hits its peak right around
three o'clock in the afternoon
so we like to be done before then
about 22 workers are at this site today
building a medical facility steinberg
diagnostic medical imaging
sr construction says they have about 200
workers spread all across the valley and
they also have a buddy system to monitor
their heat index
as we were driving around earlier this
morning searching for workers we also
came across a locksmith at a separate
site
working outdoors in these triple digits
you know you have the good times and you
have the hard times and now is the hard
times but we get used to it you know you
have
the ice just with water you have the
special hat
so alonzo says he really does not mind
this hot weather although he
says it does slow him down a bit having
to take breaks in between
to avoid heat exhaustion in this site
here again by decatur and blue diamond
road
they tell me that they go over their
safety plans every morning with a site
coordinator that stops by
to go over their osha guidelines
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys